*Creepy Ambiance*
[Mark:] AHH!
Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria Simulator.
Now this is Scott Cawthon's latest and greatest game in the Five Nights at Freddy's franchise,
Now this is Scott Cawthon's
latest and greatest game
in the Five Nights at Freddy's franchise,
BUT
But-
I don't want you to be suspicious.
I don't want you to look any deeper.
I'm sure this game is
exactly as it seems.
It's a simple
pizza tycoon game.
Where all you have to do
is design your pizza...
And feed it to the hungry boys and girls
that come by
to your establishment.
So let's get to it, shall we?
When I want a pizza,
I like a great
pepperoni and olives pizza.
So I'm gonna go with that one!
Let's go to the pizzeria, shall we?
Oh yeah!
Alright.
Ahhh!
Ooooo
Ahahaha
Ohohoho!
*more happy markimoo sounds*
ah
ooh
Alright.
Well you hungry... kids, you go
this cer-
this certainly doesn't seem like an arcade game from one of the-
this certainly doesn't seem like
an arcade game from
one of the--
(confused mumbling)
This certainly doesn't seem...
like uh...
arcade game from
various
games
such as the
like as the
Five Night's At
Got it!
AYYYYY
uh oh--
Why you still-
oo
woaH-
woa
HEYY
WOHHH
HEY
HEY!!
AUGH
WAUHGHH
*mark continues to freak out as game freaks out with him*
whOA-KAY-- ouooeh.
ah oh aigh ehm unm noh no
ah
Okay, hi.
Okay, hi. Hello, how you doin', Baby? You look like you've seen better days, Baby.
Hello
How you doin', Baby?
You look like you've seen better dayyys...
Baby...?
ough wah?
Ough What ?!
*worried laughing*
oh-houghrn
DYEH HYEH HUM NUH?
AHAHA
yea
yeah okay
Hello everybody
Welcome to Five Night's at Freddy's 6.
This is...
auohhh...
ugh
The worst-kept secret
(nervous laughing) Is that THIS GAME CAME OUT ALL OF A SUDDEN
Actually it was a really good secret 'cause even I didn't even-
I had no goddamn clue--
[Tape, male voice] Begin tape: Leaving dead space
3--2--1
3...
2...
...1
The purpose of this tape is to test automated response times and rections from vintange interative attractions
The purpose of this tape is to test automated response times and reactions from vintage
interactive attractions following audio stimuli.
[Mark] *worried* Okay...
[Tape] If you are playing this tape,
that means that not only have you been checking outside at the end of every shift,
as you were instructed to do,
But also that you have found something that meets the criteria
of your special obligations under paragraph 4.
[Mark] *worried* Hm...
[Tape] Follow these instructions,
document response times,
then safely secure the space before leaving.
[Mark] Huh?
[Tape] Upon sealing the room, you are not to return.
[Mark] Huh?!?
[Tape] Begin audio prompt in 3, 2, 1.
*extremely unpleasant metallic whining*
WHASIT WAWAH UH
WHAT AM I SUPPOSE TO DO?!
*metallic whining continues*
WHYYY?!?
[Tape] Document results.
[Mark] No...!
[Tape] Begin audio prompt in 3, 2, 1.
[Mark] I'm lookin'...
*strange howling humming noise*
[Tape] Document results.
[Mark]  Hmmmmmm NO.
[Mark] Okay! Alright!
[Tape] Begin audio prompt in 3, 2, 1
[Mark] This is WEIRD
*High-pitched metallic noise*
*Higher-pitched metallic noise*
[Mark] *growls*
*Pitch of metallic noise continues to rise*
*Unpleasantly high metallic noise*
[Mark] I hate this.
[Mark] I hate everything ABOUT THIS!!
*Unpleasantly high metallic noise*
[Tape] Document results.
[Mark] OKAY ALRIGHT
NOO.
(scritch-scratch)
I'M LOOKIN' AT YOU BABY!
[Tape] Begin audio prompt in 3...
*tape cuts off*
[Mark] Oh, fuck.
[Baby's voice] 2...
[Mark] NOOO!!
[Baby] 1.
[Mark] HOW ABOUT NOT!?!
hi
Y- that's a "Yes".
Okay...
Let me check my bOX!
Uh-hu uh Heyyy now
[Narrator] It's a new day.
It's your time to shine.
It's time to take your career into your own hands!
[Mark growls weirdly]
You saved money your whole life.
Great!
Now it's time to put all your eggs into one basket,
and take a huge gamble on your future.
A gamble that comes with a 100% chance of success in some cases.
[Mark] Purple Guy!
[Narrator] What are we talking about?
[Mark] NNOHOHO!
[Narrator] We're talking about becoming a "Fazbear Entertainment" Franchisee
[Narrator] We're talking about becoming a "Fazbear Entertainment" Franchisee.
That's right! Restaurant Ownership and Management.
Something almost anyone can do with a limited degree of success.
Sure, it's a lot of money to invest, but everyone's doing it.
And that means it's safe and lucrative.
With your initial investment, you'll receive everything you need to get started.
Including a small room, some tables, and electricity.
But don't forget about the money you have left over after buying your franchise package.
Use it to decorate, buy a stage, buy attractions and animatronics and much much more.
Now, let's take a look at a few things that will help you get started as a "Fazbear Entertainment Franchisee."
Such as,
Atmosphere!
Making sure your establishment has an inviting atmosphere is essential to bringing in new customers.
*Mark laughs in the background*
*Mark still laughing*
Entertainment!
Having a lot of entertainment value in your restaurant will ensure that costumers come back.
[Mark] Okay!
Bonus revenue!
[Mark] Oh!
Coin-operated games and attractions can generate additional revenue during the day.
[Mark] Yeah!
[Narrator] Which means more money in your pocket, ready for reinvestment.
[Mark] Okay.
[Narrator] Health and safety.
There may be times where you purchase something of questionable quality, and we don't blame you.
Cutting corners is just good business.
But there are steps you can take to ensure you don't get sued for it.
And that brings us to...
Liability.
Being a thrifty shopper is smart.
But be aware that buying things on sale comes with a certain amount of risk.
Aside from the daily risk of lawsuits,
There's also the risk that something might be hiding inside whatever you just purchased
with that steeply discounted price tag.
[Mark] Wha..?
Of course, that would only be a serious danger if there were something outside
that's been trying to get in for months now.
*Mark laughs nervously*
We are not confirming it to be the case.
This concludes the amount of help we are legally obligated to provide.
*Mark laughing*
Remember, you are now the face of the newly rebranded Freddy Fazbear's Pizza.
[Mark] That's me, baby.
[Narrator] Wear that smile with pride and let's make some money.
Fazbear Entertainment is not responsible for disappearance, death, or dismemberment.
[Mark] Ooooh...
Okay, alright, okay, okay...ah.
(Mark mumbling) Two-Step guide to restaurant management!
Use Catalog Mode to purchase item, animatronics and other supplies. Use Blueprint Mode to place [trails off unintelligibly]
Okay !
Alright !
Okay!
Great ! So, it really is a pizzeria tycoon !
Let's get started !
[Mark Laughing]Oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh, you cute little piece of shit
[Narrator] Let's see how much cash you have left over
[Mark Laughing again]
[ Narrator] after purchasing your franchise package. Great.
That should be more than enough.
Now let's get started.
[Mark] Alright
[Narrator] On your left,
are your product catalogs.
[Mark] Wow
[Narrator] You can unlock more expensive catalogs
by simply purchasing items for your pizzeria.
[Mark] Whoa
Use the arrows in the bottom right of the item window to browse the products for each catalog
[Mark] Wow
When you're finished shopping, click the button labeled "Blueprint mode" to place your items.
[Mark Oohs and Ahhs]
You can switch back and forth between catalog mode and blueprint mode as often as you like.
[Mark laughs quietly]
before opening your doors to the public.
When you're ready to open your restaurant for business for the day, click the button labeled "Finished" in blueprint mode.
Give it a try and do some shopping.
[Mark] Wow
Wow, ok , Alright
It really is! Oho, look at this!
Look at all this, stuff-- a fan!?
Hell yeah!
*Giddily* A pick--a--duck!
Oh, aw,
"Bucket Bob" unavailable, but I want "Bucket Bob"!
"Bucket Bob", ah, "Bucket Bob". Oh my go-, "Mr. Can-Do", "Mr. Hugs".
*Mark Laughing again*
*Mark Laughing* No. 1 Crate
Pan Stan
Paper Pals, I'm going to buy them!
Oh ho ho hell yeah Paper Pals!
There's a liability risk on that one,
Mr. Hugs is a little dangerous, been thinking...ohhh this is amazing
Oh yeah, hang on
We got to get the fan, that's uh, that's uh, that's a must.
I love the duck pond, that's like a gotta have and then a stage.
*Mark happy singing?*
ok, alright
Well, let's place this garbage
*Mark Laughing* then we will deal-- oh my god, oh my god
Yes, yes, yes! Sponsorship offer?
*Reading sponsorship* "Fiztime Popsoda Have a poppin' good time with Fiztime Pop".
Fiztime Pop inc. is offering to pay for advertising in your establishment-----
Accept. Yes, yes, how do I do that?
I don't---*Mumbles while laughing* How do I do that? ok
I don't have an animatronic
All right that's where that will go
Faz-Rating has gone up
No risk, absolutely----
Play test
[Soothing, cute music]
[Various "oho" and "ayy" sounds from Mark]
I got good, Point, I think. I got a lot of points
[music continues]
[music cuts off suddenly]
They were staring at me, I don't like that.
Ok, alright.
Well I got a whole lot of nothin'
*Mark chuckles* Whole lot of dick diddley
Alright, well
Ok, alright, good, great
Ok!
[Narrator begins speaking again] Your restaurant-
[Narrator] Is now officially open.
yay?
[Narrator] Awesome.
[Narrator] That doesn't mean your job is finished, however.
You have a lot of work to do, while patrons eat their pizza in the other room.
[Mark] Wuh-
[Narrator] From your terminal, you have supplies to buy,
Papers to print, and repairs to make.
Once you've taken care of all the items on your to-do list,
You can log off for the day, and get out of there.
Money for supplies and repairs comes out of petty cash,
so don't worry about it coming out of your pocket. We've got you covered.
The only money you have to worry about is if you choose to upgrade any of the equipment in your office.
[Narrator] Now on to other matters,
[Mar]} Uhhhhhh
[Narrator cont.] Something to be aware of is that the ventilation system, and your terminal, are pretty loud, and
may prevent you from hearing things in adjoining air vents.
That won't be a problem if there's nothing in the vents,
however, if you feel that something might BE in the vents,
*Mark honks Funtime Freddy's nose*
you have a few tools at your disposal to protect yourself.
You can shut off your terminal and the ventilation system at any time
To decrease the amount of attention you are drawing to yourself.
Also, shining your light directly into a vent will most likely prevent anything from jumping out.
You also have three tools available from the terminal itself.
There is a motion detector, an audio decoy, and a secondary ventilation unit.
Keep in mind, however, that you can only have one of these active at any given time.
Now get to it!
Simply log off when you've completed your tasks for the day,
and you can go get some coffee.
[Mark] WAH-
[Electronic powering down noise]
Ooh? What did I do? I didn't mean to do that.
G-alright, okay, I'm, I'm boned.
Uh, alright! Well!
[Loud music begins blaring]
[Mark] Oh no! An ad!? Oh shit-
[Mark laughs nervously while music cuts off]
[Mark screams]
Okay, alright we're fine alright we're fine I'm gonna stop screaming now.
Unclog toilets? I don't even know why-why are those a thing? Wh-
Why is that a thing?
Aaa, what am I printing and where!?
[mark moans in fear]
[mark sobs quietly]
I thought it was just gonna be fun and happy!
Oh, god, I hate this, I hate this, oh, I hate this.
That is a long time to print a flyer.
Okay, I guess we're done.
Do I have to do-
Do I have to do all of these? Before I leave? Is that what you said I had to do because I don't, really remember.
Wuh-DAMMIT GODDAMMIT!!
[quiet mechanical printer noises]
Okay, so-wait, did you hear that?
Wait.
[printer noises continue]
Wait. What is that?
Did you hear it?
[softly] wuh-
What is that? I don't know, I don't know anything that's going on here, this is completely different from anything
I've ever seen in any other Five Nights at Freddy's before!
I ain't about this shit!
I ain't about to deal with this shit!
I ain't about to lose my life!!!
wuh-Why is it taking so long to sca-
Why does it take so long to scan.
[Machine powering down noise]
Okay, everything's fine
Uh. Uh.
Everything's fine.
"Everything's fine," I keep yelling at myself. Everything's absolutely fine.
Everything is one hundred percent fine.
OKAY, DID I DO ALL MY TASKS?
Equipment...uhh log off.
[Mark] I'M DONE, I'M OUTTIE!
[Narrator] Great job! Looks like you're getting the hang of this!
[Mark yells in victory]
[Narr.] Now let's just focus on getting you through your first week.
[M] Okay...
[Narr.] There's a big party here Saturday.
[Narr.] And you should view that day as your ultimate test.
Make it through Saturday and you will have proven yourself as the successful entrepreneur that we all know you can be.
[Mark] Thank you?
[Mark] Thank you very much? I think? I'm pretty sure?
[Ominous background ambience begins]
[M] Ooh.
[Tape] Congratulations on completing your first day.
[T] However, your job isn't over just yet.
There is another aspect to your end of day routine.
And that is inspecting and salvaging any animatronics found in the alley outside the back door.
Things are found here quite often, and while we aren't sure why, what we do know is that they can be used for parts.
Which can mean a much needed revenue boost before starting your next day.
[Mark whimpers "Why?"]
[T] Of course,
[T] As with everything else in this line of work, those benefits come with risk.
The safest thing to do is to throw it back outside, but then, you get no money for the salvage.
Choose to keep it, and you run the risk of certain negative consequences. Namely, death...
Should the item in question not be as docile as it first appeared.
If you do decide to try to salvage it, then you must complete the maintenance checklist.
During this testing phase, check on the animatronic frequently.
If you feel that it is becoming unstable, use the taser provided to you.
You can use it three times without damaging the hardware.
Every use over three, however, will decrease the item's salvage value.
Before you is an animatronic found in the back alley.
We are unsure of it's origins.
It is your job to complete the maintenance checklist before claiming it as salvage.
Or, if you choose to, you can throw it back into the alley where you found it and forfeit payment.
Please make your choice now.
[Mark] Uh. Alright, we'll salvage it!
[Tape] You have chosen to proceed with the maintenance checklist.
[Mark] Yeah
[Tape Man] Remember, use your company issued taser to return the animatronic to a neutral state if you feel that it's becoming unstable or aggressive.
You can only use it three times before it begins to damage the animatronic, and decrease its value.
[T] Begin audio prompt in 3...2...1.
[Strange, warbling mechanical noise]
[Mark] I'm watchin you!
[Tape] Document results.
[Mark] Okay, nope!
[M]Ohh, wait, he moved......Wait.....He moved!
[T] Begin audio prompt in three.. two... one...
[Strange warbling mechanical noise returns]
[Mark] What are you doin'?
[Strange warbling mechanical noise]
[Tape] Document results.
[Pencil scratch]
[Mark] No, heeeey! You!
[T] Begin audio prompt in 3...2...1.
[Mark] Don't you do nothin'.
[Hitching, whirring noises]
[T] Document results.
[Mark] Aah...okay.
[T] Begin audio prompt in 3...2...1.
[Strange mechanical warbling noise, with more whirs this time]
[Mark groans]
[T] Document results.
[M] 'Kay.
[ominous ambience]
[M] Uh-oh, why?
What? What's happening. Uh.
[T] Begin audio prompt in 3...2...1.
[Mechanical grinding and distorted noise, warbling, Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria jingle distored in background]
[Mechanical clang and scream]
[Mark screams]
[M] Ooookay alriiiight alright alri-
[Mechanical laugh]
[High-pitched, sing-song Funtime Freddy voice] I'm here!
[M] Oooh- Something is loose in my pizzeria!?
[Soft, peppy music and sound effects]
[M] What!?
[Mark whimpers in confusion]
[M] Something's loose in my pizzeria??
*high and fearful* What does that mean?
[M] Wha...
[Mark stutters]
Uh...Gumball Swivelhands?
Neon stage lights? Sturdy stage? Marked down?
Wow. Condition terrible.
Ungh...oh...ah, Purchasing a bulky item in this condition comes with a significant risk of something undesirable hiding inside!
I'll buy that, it's at a discount! (Nervous giggle)
Oho ho! Novelty traffic light!
Happy frog!
Mr. Hippo!
Nedd Be-*laughs* Nedd Bear.
Right, Nedd Bear.
Pigpatch. Cadet-Candy Cadet.
I'm gonna buy, Nedd Bear.
Im'ma buy Nedd Bear. (In a weird accent)
Nedd Bear gonn' make you- your- your-
your- establishment real good like. Nedd Bear..
N-Nedd Bear do good...for youuu, Nedd Bear is best bear..
Alright, let's place these bad boys.
Nedd Bear, you're-Nedd Bear, you're up, oh boy, wow, oh wow Nedd Bear.
You know what, Nedd Bear, I don't feel too good about this Nedd Bear?
Nedd Bear I gotta, gotta admit, gotta admit, don't feel, don't feel too strongly about this, safety straps-[laughs]
[While laughing] Add a coin slot?
I dunno if I want that, I dunno if I want that at all.
[Groans]
Let's play- test this bad boy
[Peppy music starts]
Ooh. Press space.
Unh, shit!
[Bone cracking sound as Tiny Fredbear lands. Music abruptly ends]
[Mark laughs incredulously]
[Music resumes and he laughs harder]
Oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy!
[Bone cracking noise, music ends. Mark imitates the noise and resumes laughing]
Oh boy oh boy oh boy!
Unh, yaay! I maaade it. Yes!
Oh, another one... [laughing softly] I was hoping that it'd be done after three!
[Laughs] Oh, jeez.
Uh, unh, yes! That counts!
[More laughter]
Oh my god, oh my god that is so funny.
Alright alright we're good here. We're good. We're good.
Sponsorship?! Hell, yeah.
What? Nothing goes down that can't come up!
That doesn't sound good. Alright, advertising. Perfect.
[Laughing] Let's put some coin slots on these bad boys! Alright.
Coin slot...let's put some safety straps...
There we go! Alright, safety stra-[starts laughing]
[More laughter]
Alright! How ya doin!
Ah, you're good, you're good, alright, let's do this-[sniff]
Mm, something's loose in the...establishment.
[Mechanical sounds]
Oh boy.
[Sigh] Okay, so we just gotta order these..shit..and we're good!
Does that look like a bird beak to you?
Kinda looks like a bird beak to me.
Okay I'll just-
I'm just knocking these things down, I ain't- I ain't waitin for nobody.
[mechanical noise]
[Mark starts exclaiming] Wuh-Why-Wa-Wa-Wa-
OH-OH-Hi-Woah-I-
I'm dead!?
[Molten Freddy/Ennard] Together again!
I didn't even hear a noise, there was nothing!
There was just-happen!
[Mark groans] Aaaahh, what!?
What!?
Where do I pick up I don't even know!
I don't even understand!!
oh-Lots of-wait, what?
Fun? Oh.
Uh.
[Slightly more freaked out] Uh. Uh. Okay?
You can stop that now.
Yknow, that's enough. I think that's enough.
You can stop.
Oh boy. Wh- okay that's enough! That's e-jeh-[mumbles]
Slow down-stop the train! Put brakes on this bad boy! [Makes braking noise]
Pull into-stop station!
Any day now? Okay, here we go I guess we're goin.
Gonna be lots of fun. Lots of fun, fun, fun, fun, fun-
Fun, fun fun fun-[sped up mark saying fun]  Fun, Fun, Fun!
(Cheesy '90s-esque theme music) Ah, ooo, ah. Oh, ah.
Why does this look like Dream Daddy? Why does it look like Dream Daddy?!
Okay, so anyway, that is all the time I got for this one.
I will continue this very soon. This is Five Nights at Freddy's 6 if you wanna call it that?
But also,
It's just a whole grab bag of weird and scary and awesome, so.
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Lemme know what you think down in the comments below!
Lemme know if you've got any more theories about this game, I'll provide a link to the game in the description below
You can get it offa Steam.
And thanks everybody so much for watching! Buckle up for a wild ride cuz this one's gonna be weird and awesome.
So thanks again, and as always, I will see you! In the next video. Buh-Byeeee!